was ist das für eine frage wie ist die
lage ich wünsche mir gerade eine massage
von herbergen in der rückenlage ich
penetriert sie wie eine mückenplage das
heißt du bist alter metal aber nur wir
gewesen ja ich habe meine anfänge im
deutschen web gemacht außer jetzt texte
von fantastischen vier nachzusingen in
der rba wendiger battle alina das war
glaube ich von dem sie damals geworden
wird anfang der 90er mitte der 90er war
das da hatte ich auch fa quasi
kennengelernt kommt eigentlich fragen
sich viele
ja er macht gerade ich weiß nicht ob man
das sagen darf
namenswechsel auch durch ok und da kommt
wieder war es ja jetzt haben es gesagt
letztes jahr öfter mal der fall
ja klar sicher ist ja auch nichts
verwerfliches dabei ihr habt auch den
namen gewechselt oder der gewechselt
sondern die haben sich weiterentwickelt
so warf er vor nur zwieback ich war ganz
anfänglich war ich nur zwieback danach
onkels wie war ich hab mir den beinamen
onkel gegeben um weil die meisten leute
heißt ein bmw bloody geschlagen nicht
tot und dann ist findet sie und die dir
immer so amerikanisch und wir haben ja
auch in deutschland dagegen habe ich
gedacht onkel ist witzig ist schon mal
selbstironisch
das bin ich gut und viele bugs wibag ist
das heilmittel für deutsche musik und
speisen sich nicht wie ein verdauung ist
ja ich habe eigentlich wirklich meine
hand lange in sophies des eifers und so
gemacht und dann braucht man halt
irgendeinen haben einfach um sich zu
behaupten um zu sagen können ja ich bin
gerade am main und dann habe ich gedacht
ich lieber warum gleich trockener humor
auch gut so denn die weil das ist euer
album wo habe ich schon jetzt hier von
zwieback und die asi beide ist eher
humoristisch angelegt sicherlich auch es
ging nicht darum
parodie album oder comedy album zu
machen aber ist natürlich steckt sehr
viel selbstironie drin ganz klar und es
ist genre übergreifend auf jeden fall
also ich könnte es jetzt nicht
kategorisieren würde ich auch nicht
versuchen wollen es sicherlich ist rock
drin dieses web drin ist das pop auf
jeden fall drin von den harmonien
es ist nichts gesampelt anders selber
produziert eigene spielt abgemischt
aber ja humor ist dabei okay es geht
auch habe ich wieder festgestellt und da
sind natürlich mit ein bisschen ans
letzte interview mit dir es geht auch
wieder um scheiße und als du gerade um
die ecke gegangen bist
sogar um die ecke vista hat zwar gesagt
und abruzzen nicht vergessen und meinte
das müsse man die auch immer sagen ja im
gegensatz zu der er verbal inkontinent
ist kommt es bei mir noch am richtigen
los
ok heißt das dass wir meinen texten die
meisten texte von ihnen sind oder wie
funktioniert die zusammenarbeit da also
ich würde jetzt zum beispiel sagen bei
dem titel zunge weg der mir wirklich
einen mittleren brechreiz verursacht hat
was auch glaube ich beabsichtigt ist der
bestand aus seiner feder zone weg oder
ich muss 14 der kompletten tag und
handelt von einer von einem liebesakt
mit durchfall
dieser text ist tatsächlich von 2 sowie
die meisten texte die wir machen die
dann eher bisschen die richtung geht wie
sind und andere bei denen man es nicht
erwartet
die vielleicht sehr ernst sind er dann
von mir sind okay und um die frage noch
komplett verantworten
es ist wirklich 50 50 also wir haben
wirklich das album fast zu gleichen
teilen gemacht ich habe texte
geschrieben er hat texte geschrieben und
unsere kreativen momente waren auch
gleich aufgeteilt das war immer so gott
sei dank das ist nicht parallel war
sondern mal hatte ich wirklich so ein
leidensdruck dass ich ins studio
gekommen bin und gesagt
komm lass los legen und dann ging es
irgendwie zehn stunden am stück bis alle
sachen eingespielt war und am ende kam
alles raus was wir selbst nicht erwartet
haben um mal war er drauf aber so
richtig drauf also drei tage lang war
sie wirklich wie auf droge ein song nach
dem anderen eingespielt eingesungen
texte geschrieben wie im rausch
eigentlich und das war cool dass noch
eine coole sache okay kommt man die kann
man die eigentlich bei kommen ich weiß
es ja aus eigener erfahrung das ist
schwer
wie kommt es dann von einer 50 50
zusammenarbeiten
was weißt du denn aus eigener erfahrung
das interview wildtiere sondern ist als
angriff überhaupt nicht aber ich warte
mal wie sie ist mir die sauer auf dich
ja ja nein es ist ja also auch in sein
letztes gespräch war ja eigentlich
geprägt von latenten zuneigung die wir
ein bisschen verborgen haben hinter
floskeln oder ironie aber prinzipiell
bin ich erst mal ein mensch der seinem
gegenüber sehr aufgeschlossen ist und
auch sehr neugierig entgegentritt und
auch das war mit andere der fall als wir
uns kennengelernt haben waren wir beide
in unterschiedlichen welten
ich kam aus der comedy andré war
produzent und sagst du zu sagen studie
und dann relativ schnell festgestellt
das ist eine kreative schnittmenge gibt
und die auf den punkt zu bringen auch in
dem wir musik machen indem er texte
schreiben war die beste idee die wir
haben konnten das ist jetzt das zweite
album das wir zusammen machen und wir
haben immer noch einen riesenspaß
eigentlich inklusive aller schwulitäten
die man sich vorstellen kann
ok dann bei der sich zum thema schwule
ich bin dafür also ich hab dem
eigentlich nichts hinzuzufügen das war
auf den punkt gebracht wir haben uns
kennengelernt wo habt ihr über wollte
ich gerne sagen über das motto kabarett
album von caro kebekus
da hat es ja dann feature draufgemacht
damals das war 2011 will ich mich
richtig sind
detto kabarett erhältlich jetzt nach
bartz an genau das thema von broken
comedy halt aufgegriffen und ein ganzes
album zu gemacht
rebecca soni
denn und incredible ich kenne das video
mit dir und mutter lucia ja das witzige
ist es das witzige ist es gibt ja solche
videos tatsächlich aus porz ja es gibt
so muss man gucken ja ja und die sind
nicht treten die drehen natürlich die
videos auch da wo ihr sie geben
die besitzer hätten ja echt ganz kleine
schwester aber eine riesen klappe und
das nachzumachen war total lustig die
haben das aber nicht verstanden wissen
die frage ist wie kriegt man das
überhaupt den pass auf es gibt ja hier
einen titel
ich würde mal sagen der zielt ein wenig
dicke eier hat da ist er
der zählt ja ein bisschen auf das web
wissen sie ich würde sogar sagen wenn
ich hier erwarte man warte mal wo die
programme der bewerber aber was wir
deutsche rapper sind arm
ja genau warte mal war genau mein text
ist als lösen oder wartet ein flug auf
arafat apel und dann gibt's irgendeine
schrift wird es im video wie hast du cup
oder toccata so gar nicht die türkischen
backpfeife naja tokat eigentlich wort zu
viel jazz liefert die türkischen
bergvolk ducatis lieber greift genau an
doch schon hast du viel erklärt ich weiß
jetzt pass auf wo ist es wo es so hepp
und wo ist es verarschung gibt es
überhaupt eine grenze wo sie sagt selber
den verstehen gar nicht zum teil wo die
ironie anfängt und wo es echt ist oder
ist das echte schon ironie also in
meiner noch kurzen auseinandersetzung
mit dem genre hip hop habe ich vor allem
eins gelernt dass nicht nur die hip
hopper selbst sondern auch ihre fans
sehr humorlos sind okay und dass sie
sehr viel austeilen aber ganz wenig nur
einstecken können und dass ein bisschen
auf die spitze zu treiben und zu sagen
bleibt man locker wir machen euch nur
nach das war auch unser anliegen aber
wir haben auch durchaus
ärzte seiten in dem album wo es nicht
nur darum geht sondern gebäude
liebeslieder ja wo es um kinder bord zum
beispiel auch geht auch liebeslied aber
eben mit einem tragischen ende und das
war das was wir auch besonders fanden
dass wir gesagt haben wir sind keiner
linie verpflichtet keine image dass
irgendein verlag uns ausdrückt sondern
wir sind wir wir machen das worauf wir
bock haben und das ist sehr
unterschiedlich
es gibt auch bei liebeslieder über habe
ich fest hast mir nicht zugehört du
jetzt in der schneider
sie haben fragen zu stellen es gibt ja
aber ist auch eine technisch man im
fernsehen es ist eine technik entwickelt
oder und sichern brauche ich das gesehen
weil irgendwer chartshow und mittag mit
mirja boes und dann wie heißt der
moderator noch hier
da wir mit den burschen kopf der starter
gedächtnis zu stellen was wäre für meine
gesellschaften zu stellen ich kenne
diese ich gucke ja kein fernsehen mehr
wie heißt der police story nicht ich
kenne und sagt wie heißt der monatlich
war das doch es geht um die chartshow
mit oliver geissen und dann blättert dir
genau wie ich rum und dann sagt er hast
du überhaupt zugehört es ist oft so du
bist auch zum beispiel in dubai so
meistens ist es so bei dritten
programmen da ist so ein redakteur
stellt eine frage die aus wikipedia sich
zusammen gesammelt hat und während du
antwortest cook der weg oder macht so
schreibt notizen und ja da muss man
spielen kann sich wieder anders und
genau da kann ich die fragen genau sagen
kann sich die frage nach her natürlich
darauf will die sind ja aufgezeichnet
auch zu machen jetzt habe ich aber
wirklich alle anderen einreihen
ich wollte mich auf deine antwort
durchaus beziehen nämlich auf die
liebeslieder du hattest die aber dann
eben immer schlimm enden ja die enden
oder ich sag mal so wunderbar brechen
plötzlich ein horizont auf mit dem man
überhaupt nicht gerechnet hat hier hat
man eine hyper sexuelle das ist geil das
ist ein lied über den nymphomanin ja
warst du schon mal mit einer frau
zusammen
olsen wollte überall sagt ich nicht aber
gleich zeichen dass ich die antwort mehr
ein bilden kann
okay ich habe das nicht nachvollziehen
können aber das haus hart sein
ja das ist zum teil hart das ist man
zwar auch schön wenn es so im auto
fährst und sagt komm lass ranfahren
kriegt mich aber es ist auch anstrengend
weil wenn du dauernd wie dahin halten
muss der und so sogar das auch ist ist
irgendwann schluss dann kommt nichts
mehr
es gibt ja werk also muss ja auch nichts
mehr kommen er ist also ich finde es
gibt so eine kerze also pro stunde fünf
mal finde ich schon sehr viel wert
gewesen nein das uns erst zu beantworten
war eine parodie auf eine
liebesbeziehung in der der typ
eigentlich der sonst die große schnauze
hat das totale weichei ist und sagt ich
bin ich haben und ich in der
öffentlichkeit und du willst ständig ich
mir noch nicht ein sexobjekt und was
waren wir etwas nur verlustig okay du
offensichtlich nicht ich konnte halt
nicht so nachvollziehen ich sag mal das
sind weil du sagst aber fast mich bitte
an vor allem in der öffentlichkeit aber
wie sind die idee jetzt wenn du mich
fragst ob ich mit einer informatik schon
mal zusammen war sind das in
anführungszeichen autobiografische leben
oder ist das sind das sachen hat jetzt
auch für mich
oder sind eher sachen die euch einfach
in solchen arbeitsphasen in den kopf
kommt und ihr um ihr wählt rom spielt
teils teils natürlich ein album entsteht
ja nicht nur aus eigener erfahrung
sondern oft sind auch themen mit dem man
sich zwar irgendwo identifizieren kann
aber manchmal auch team mit dem man sich
selber gar nicht identifizieren kann wie
celine zum beispiel wo es um ein
kindermörder gehören ja also es ist
einfach das ziel war kreativ zu seinen
spaß zu haben im studio und so sind halt
16 werke sind in ordnung
16 werke entstanden die eigentliche
unterschiedlich sind sowohl inhaltlich
als auch von den tonarten und den
geschwindigkeiten und sehr variabel
nichtsdestotrotz ist ein roter faden
drin was man ja mal was ist das für ein
album
ich war mir nicht so ganz sicher ist es
comedy
es sind wir beide muss man das definiert
ist es wichtig immer wieder bei dem
ewigen thema gibt es schubladen braucht
man schubladen
also was du was du von uns verlangt ist
hier dass wir uns selbst kategorisieren
und warum sollten wir das tun um
gefährlich zu sein leute zum essen zu
verkauf ja genau
bitte bitte kauft unsere cd ist auf zehn
glocken wandern kann sie nicht einordnen
missbrauch des rockers des hip hop es
ist ein hybrid aus allem was wir sind du
bist doch auch wenn du heute hier sitzt
ein teil dessen ein stück dessen was du
im gesamten darstellt manchmal bist du
erster bist journalist manchmal bist du
albern manchmal bist du wahrscheinlich
kann aber letztlich kennen dich nicht du
kommst aus köln und das wollten wir auch
sehr präsent eine sache an diesem album
ist uns beiden sehr wichtig das ist echt
ist das spiel ist und das nicht nur
dessen verlag oder eine industrie
dahinter steckt die uns sagt wie wir zu
sein haben damit leute uns mögen
und deswegen haben wir das von anfang an
zur maxime gemacht dass wir gesagt haben
wir machen das ohne dass jemand uns geld
gibt und wir uns verpflichtet fühlen
sondern nur weil wir das machen wollen
jetzt klingelt mein telefon redet man
weiß ja ja wäre immer weiter du als
musikproduzent ja jemand der dann schon
alben gemacht hat die in eine bestimmte
schublade passen absolute da für mich
jetzt schwierig gewesen musst du über
deinen schatten springen oder war das
eine befreiung das ist ja weder noch
eigentlich also ich hab natürlich wenn
man für bestimmte künstler musik
produziert dann sind ja schon in einem
genre drin und man bedient das einfach
nur insofern also ich musste jetzt nicht
über meinen schatten springen
ich habe in der alle möglichen
richtungen schon produziert oder habt
ihr diskutiert wir müssen doch immer du
kannst du ab und dies und das und kommen
wissen ja auch nicht so viele leute dass
er früher also eigentlich kommt er aus
der musik schlagzeug studiert hat er
klavier im nebenfach und irgendwas mit
kompositionen glaube ich auch und ich
war ja schon immer im hip hop eigentlich
zu hause ich habe schon um die 30
releases album habe ich acht stück
glaube ich alleine produziert und
da liegt es für mich natürlich nahe in
welche richtung ich eigentlich gehe oder
was das fundament meiner musik ist das
war immer web das wird es auch immer
bleiben auch wenn ich jetzt ein bisschen
mehr in der pop richtung vielleicht
gelandet bin weil ich mich musikalisch
weiterentwickelt hat und so ist das
einfach so eine fusion gewesen aber das
kohle ist eben das coole ist eben und
das ist außergewöhnlich dass diese
zusammenarbeit sehr homogen war oder
sagen aber das richtige wort
weil es oft so ist wenn man im studio
ist läuten die im geltungsbedürfnis
haben dass man sich stößt aneinander und
nicht wie in unserem fall sich ergänzt
und das heißt er hat kein
geltungsbedürfnis hingegen seien ein
nein das ist ja ein klischee dass ich so
ein übermäßiges geltungsbedürfnis habe
dass ich andere neben mir nicht machen
dazu sondern andré ist für mich ein
absolut vollwertiger partner gewesen
dessen wort auch sehr wichtig war und
dessen ideen auch für mich absoluten
wert hatten die kunst war diese beiden
ideen in einen topf zu bringen nur mal
als beispiel wenn dann ich meine
kreative phase hatte und dann irgendwie
irgendwo im kopf hatte pulpo komma
strich fertig ist dass das kind wie gut
und dann er prompt hat gesagt dann
machen wir dann hast du fertig ist das
erklärte der ps vita ist das weiß man
nicht
und da war dann einfach die
schnittmengen wo wir gesagt alter das
geht so kulas mehr machen und nächste
tag andré kommt sagte ich habe eine
nummer lebt genauso los ich mache den
beat und zack ist die nächste nummer
fertig und das war echt richtig harte
großer wert ist das immer so oder ist
das hat das was mit der chemie zwischen
euch zu tun oder ist das etwas was man
sich erarbeiten muss also nur als
beispiel kollegen den ich sehr schätze
aber der auch sehr sehr anstrengend ist
es heftig sven okay weil der explodiert
vor ideen da kommt die studie dass nur
denken
im moment haben wir müssen erstmal den
strohmann machen und kostüme und so hat
ist eine tattoo zweifel und senkt alter
den katzen nicht mehr handeln ist
durchgeknallt was am ende rauskommt ist
natürlich mega lustig und total geil
aber bleibt man mit dem zehn wochen hin
zum studio das ist psychoterror und das
ist bei euch nicht der fall
es ist so gezielt wir haben carla der
und ist dabei von andré deep end auf dem
sofa wir erzählen erstmal es geht
erstmal drei stunden und gar nichts dann
trinken kaffee und andere macht nebenbei
irgendwie oder ich habe einen bass in
der hand und spiegel sagt etwas hört
sich cool an
und zack kommen wir in so ein floh das
ist eigentlich um dieses beispiel der
homosexuellen beziehung etwas zu
vertiefen
eigentlich wie eine liebesbeziehung in
der in der es eine gute atmosphäre geben
muss damit man zu höchstleistungen musik
nicht immer eine liebesbeziehung des
musikers mit der musik der musiker
untereinander weil es sonst vielleicht
nicht funktioniert weil du sagst es gibt
ausgesprochen fruchtbare stimmt musiker
beziehung wie serie a die die serie
erfüllt sind
es ist also auch das kann motor sein ist
letztendlich geht es um die schnittmenge
die man behält obwohl man sich
vielleicht nicht mag oder ob man sich
sehr mag weiß man nicht aber das was
dabei rauskommt wird ein produkt das
eine kontur hat dass er an charisma hat
und ich möchte sich behaupten dass wir
schon am ende unserer reise sind das ist
mein zweites album nach langer zeit in
der ich keine musik gemacht habe andrea
hat eine ganz andere musik gemacht kommt
jetzt so bisher in dem hobby dem bereich
aber wir lernen dazu und wir merken auch
umzugehen mit der rezeption der leute
und gelassen zu bleiben und zu sagen
pass auf das ist ein momentaner zustand
die wir haben den habe festgehalten
darauf sind total stolz
und was danach kommt auch wir uns
verpflichtet fühlen für etwas was davor
war das sein frage gestellt für uns im
moment nicht
ich würde nur ein schade um das
abschließend zu dieser frage zu sagen
dass heute sehr viele leute unglaublich
schnell urteilen und auch wenn ich dich
fragen oder andere leute frage hast du
das album hört ja ich hab mal reingehört
und wie findest es nun ja jahre
ich wünschte mir einfach weiß wir haben
uns sehr viel aufwand gemacht und sehr
viel mühe gemacht
wirklich explizit am nummern zu feilen
dass leute dem auch gerecht werden indem
sie bei itunes kann man sich jede nummer
130 anhören indem sie sich einlassen und
dann urteilen
es ist mir zu poppig ist es mit zu wenig
hip hop ich oder mein star haftbefehl
kann es besser und dann okay damit kann
ich leben aber mit diesem
oberflächlichen urteil was er bei meinem
ersten album ganz eklatant war was bist
du schwul war schließlich mit dem kann
ich überhaupt nichts anfangen weil das
ist so da haben leute geklickt 50 kunden
geguckt sagt das ist nicht mal das was
ich vorher kannte weg und dann ist es
natürlich ungerecht und denkst und wofür
70 20 wochen im studio und wir machen
uns über jeden [ __ ] gedankenspielen sein
wenn leute doch wirklich nur eine
sekunde damit verbringen
das heißt du möchtest auch dass ich vor
so im interview das album so mindestens
zehn anwärtern
nein ich möchte dass leute sich
intensiver mit dingen beschäftigen und
interesse und neugier haben für dinge
und nicht einfach in dem katalog das
abarbeiten und schnell ihre meinung
bilden damit es irgendwo steht was man
lesen kann auf twitter oder facebook
oder was weiß ich wo und gefällt mir
gefällt mir nicht klicken kann wie oft
cliquen leute im affekt gefällt mir habe
es ihr noch gar nicht gesehen wenn ich
heute ein video post dass zehn minuten
dauert habe ich in zehn sekunden schon
abgehört likes ja wo hast du das video
gesehen wo ab
aber und das ist etwas was mich total
ärgert heutzutage ich wünsche mir
natürlich bin ich manchmal auch schnell
ungerecht vielleicht sagen gerechter
abwägung aber ich mache mir besonders
bei sachen von denen ich weiß dass sie
von anderen auf richtig gemacht worden
die mühe mit einer ähnlichen
aufrichtigkeit mich damit auseinander zu
setzen sonst wird man der sache einfach
nicht geruht aber da muss man dazu sagen
du bist künstler ein zuhörer oder
zuschauer ist nicht unbedingt künstler
er hat nicht unbedingt die möglichkeit
aber du hast um in ein werk 1 da steckte
mich weder hinter dem begriff künstler
noch halte ich ihn einfach aber es ist
so so haben wir haben vermutlich kann
hat die gabe so ein album sich an zu 130
wirst ja noch aushalten ja deutlich
entspannen von arx am kreis schon aber
es ist doch auch ein zeichen der zeit
nur um das mal plan zu politisieren
rtl die ganzen sender die setzen ja auch
darauf dass schnell meinung ja aber
wenig format natürlich bauer sucht frau
gegen ein von gross plant ja aber an
sollten gerade in der musikindustrie
finde ich da gibt es eine gegenbewegung
ich finde dass dort viel weniger es gibt
natürlich immer noch die super stars die
total schlechte flache und sonstwas
musik machen aber ich finde gerade
dadurch dass musik nur noch gekauft wird
wenn sie wirklich gut ist hat dadurch
aus einer gegenbewegung stadt befinden
also ich finde auch dass es dann
entwicklung gibt in mehr qualität gute
musik also gerade den letzten jahren
sind so viele gute musiker auf dem plan
jetzt muss ich namen aufschwung coldplay
crowe finde ich ist jetzt macht eine
gute musik für eine bestimmte zielgruppe
ist aber ist für mich schon mainstream
aber komplett wenn ich zum beispiel
supergruppe findet fantastische musik
gefällt mir super gut
ich sage mir ich könnte der 20
betriebsinhaber musiker nennen die
wirklich hoch qualitative musik musik
machst dir gentleman patrice und so
überhaupt nicht aber sein also es gibt
wirklich wahnsinnig viel gute musik und
wenn ich das mit den 80ern vergleich
woods wahnsinnig viel schlechte musik
gab aber christoph hein sage ich ja okay
das mag leuten gefallen haben die auf
die kritik der und blonde frauen
schreien auch das ist delegieren
einigen wir uns doch darauf musik bleibt
ist und war immer schon geschmackssache
und das wird sich nicht ändern ich kann
niemandem eine musik zurechtlegen die
ihm passt was mich nur ärgert ist dass
es eine industrie gibt die versucht das
zu machen und sie macht es auch nur sehr
geschickte art und weise so dass leute
auch drauf reingefallen
also nehmen wir mal beispielsweise rtl
mal mein lieblingsthema der sender
früher haben die plattenfirmen sich die
arroganz geleistet zu sagen wir
entscheiden im stillen kämmerlein wenn
wir zum star machen und nicht und die
motive und die faktoren nachdem sie
stars erkoren haben waren
markttechnische motiven also welcher
jüngere hast in das bild der bravo
lesern den wir jetzt zum star machen
können das hatte mit musik wenig zu tun
irgendwann kam rtl dazu was wir machen
das vor den augen
zuschauer wir beteiligen die an diesem
prozess wir zeigen ihnen sogar wie diese
untalentierte dämliche sackt plötzlich
zum superstar gemacht wird in dem ein
bisschen schminke aufs gesicht bekommen
und plötzlich hoppelt wie ein pop
häschen und die leute was haben sie
gemacht die haben nicht gesagt sie zeigt
uns dass ihr uns verarscht und dass die
industrie so perfide ist auch noch geld
daran zu verdienen dass sie es uns zeigt
so die leute habe es gekauft mark
medlock ist auf platz eins gegangen
dieser straßenstrich aus offenbach der
resozialisierungsmaßnahmen ist ich
plötzlich deutschlands größter superstar
geworden warum weil rtl die macht hatte
mit seiner quote die leute zur kasse zu
treiben inklusive aller seiner neben
medien und den leuten zu suggerieren das
ist ein star und das ist etwas was mich
ärgert
ja das ist mit sicherheit aber dsds hat
immer schlechtere quoten also von daher
ist doch ein silberstreif am horizont zu
erkennen
aber das ist genau das ist für mich das
alte wie macht man musik wie macht man
stars war da kommt ja nicht warum da
kommt nichts gutes warum aber hier im um
jetzt mal ein schlusswort zu finden wir
diese wir machen ja noch ein paar andere
sachen
hier ist was bei rumgekommen es lohnt
sich auf jeden fall das anzuhören
ab 20 september im handel
warum sagen dass ich manchmal 27
september wurde es falsch kommuniziert
ich war
frankfurt und wie wir jetzt gelernt
haben die beiden haben da sehr viel
herzblut reingesteckt und es sind zum
teil ihre tiere texte das kann man
glaube ich sagen aber ich glaube das ist
auch explizit so gewollt dass mit der
zunge weg der hatten ja zu einziger aber
es gibt auch andere texte wie warum
siehst du immer so aus als hätte man die
gerade den schwanz aus dem mund gemacht
hat nicht irritieren manche kommen sehen
halt so aussehen wie ich habe mir diese
frau thomalla
hallo okay da weißt du hast ganz so
schob rausgezogen die lippen sind doch
so haben den rest der eichel noch in der
form aber das ist ja eben das was ich an
dieser stelle dieses gespräch mitgehört
los lass uns drüber schwierig auf
widerstand die eiche